[MUSIC PLAYING]
MISHA BRUKMAN: Today
we'll talk about--
Accelerating IoT, FinServ,
and Supply Chain Innovation
with JanusGraph and Bigtable.
My name is Misha Brukman.
I'm a product manager on
Google Cloud Bigtable.
I'm also a co-founder and
member of the Technical Steering
Committee for JanusGraph, an
open source-distributed graph
database.
And with me today, we have
Brian Hall from Expero.
Brian.
BRIAN HALL: My
name's Brian Hall.
I'm with Expero, a consultancy.
We've been working
with graph databases
and doing graph projects for
the better part of five years.
We've been involved with
the JanusGraph initiative
since its inception.
And one of our senior
architects is a co-founder
with Misha on the committee.
It's my hope today
that when you're done,
you have a good grounding
in JanusGraph and why
you might get excited and can
pick a good use case with which
to deploy this technology.
What we'll walk through
today is a little bit
about graph databases
for those of you
that don't know
anything about them yet.
We'll talk a little
bit about why
marrying graph with
time series data
is a very powerful paradigm.
We'll walk through how
that manifests itself
in a few different use cases
in IoT, financial services,
and supply chain.
And then at the end,
Misha will walk you
through how you would actually
make this happen on GCP.
It's important to note
that while what we're
talking about here
today is reasonably new,
the mathematical foundations
upon which it's built
have been around for millennia.
The original graph
problem was solved
by a Swiss mathematician
in the 1700s
by the name of Leonhard Euler.
And he solved the famous
intractable problem
called the Bridges
of Koenigsberg
by reducing it to what is now
known as modern graph theory.
It turns out that a lot of the
same things, same paradigms
and concepts, that he
used to solve this problem
are also useful for solving
your tricky Sudoku puzzle
as well as determining
the fewest number of moves
to swap positions
on a chess board.
A little more tangibly,
there are several real world
algorithms that can be put to
use, clustering, betweenness,
similarity.
We all know what page
rank is good for.
I would recommend that you
look at some of the URLs
at the end of the presentation.
There are several great recipes
on the TinkerPop website
with graph algorithms
and good use
cases as to when to use them.
Graphs are modeled in the
real world all over the place.
Transportation networks
can be modeled as graphs.
Computer networks and IoT
The canonical social network
that we're all familiar with
can be modeled in a graph.
Interestingly, the first
commercial database, IBM's IMS,
modeled a graph as
a bill of materials
in the late '60s for
the Saturn V project.
When we talk about
graph databases,
one flavor is known as
the RDF triplestore.
It stands for Resource
Description Format.
Coming out of research
around the semantic web
in the late '90s, it consists of
a three-part tuple-- a subject,
predicate, and object.
In this case, I've
got Brian is a person.
Misha is a person.
Brian knows Misha.
These are all examples
of RDF triples.
SPARQL is the query language.
And this is not
what JanusGraph is.
So the second category
of graph database
is something called a
property graph, where you
have both vertices and edges.
Each of them may
have properties.
And edges are directed.
While SPARQL is the lingua
franca for RDF triples,
there are various
query languages
to be used against
property graphs.
JanusGraph is a property graph.
And the query language
that we use here
is something called Gremlin.
When we work with clients
all over the place,
we try to pick the right
use case and ask them,
is the graph a good
fit for this use case?
So usually it consists of a
couple different questions.
Are there natural
networks in my data?
And do I have to traverse
the graph in order
to get the answers to
the questions I'm asking?
Oftentimes, we
work with clients,
and the answer to the
first question is yes,
second question is no.
For instance, in the
supply chain use case,
I might think that graph
would be a good application
if I, for instance, was
looking to see an outage
and how it might ripple
through my supply chain.
But conversely, if I'm
trying to figure out
what is the net sum
total of widgets
in my suite of
warehouses, that's
kind of a classic SQL use case.
So it's always
important to make sure
that you pick the right use
cases and the right problems
when you deploy this technology.
But when you do find
the right problem,
it can be a very concise
and elegant solution
to the questions you're asking.
This example here is a dirt
simple recommendation engine,
where on the left, you see a
14-table inner and outer join,
and on the right, you see a
very concise Gremlin query.
This is actually built
under the premise
that if you and I have nine of
the same products in common,
and I have the 10th one,
you're likely to also want
that 10th one.
What we also find in many
cases is marrying a graph
database with a
time series data can
be a very powerful paradigm.
What we end up
modeling frequently
are atomic unit
snapshots in time,
where I'm capturing a
stock price on a given day
or a reading on an IoT sensor.
And then as I stack
them together,
then I've got a time series.
So this gives me the
micro view of what
is happening at any
given point in time
and how it trends over time.
When I marry that with a
graph, what I can also do
is get a bigger sense of how
these things are interrelated
and possibly
understand causality.
Why is this thing trending
up while the other thing
is trending down?
If I see either of them on their
own, I don't have that context.
If I see it modeled as
a graph in conjunction
with the time
series, then I might
be able to understand
the relations
and possibly even predict where
things might go in the future.
So how does this manifest itself
in use cases in the real world?
So for these use cases that
we're going to walk through,
one in each of the industries,
we'll outline the problem.
We'll walk through a little bit
about how you would model it
in a property graph.
We'll walk through the use case
of how we exploit this data
model, so that you understand
the processing involved.
And then in a
couple of examples,
we'll walk through
some user interfaces
about how this would
manifest itself
if you were going to
build a finished product.
As a reminder, all
the things that you're
going to see here
in a second, these
are all property graph models
with vertices and edges.
And each of them
may have properties.
Edges are directed.
Some of these graphs
are a little bit busy.
So we've dropped some of the
properties just for clarity.
So how would I do this
in an IoT setting?
This model that I'm
going to walk through
is useful and can be
kind of translated
in several different scenarios.
One would be computer networks.
I could model this as
sensors in the oil and gas
industry, industrial
networks, power grids,
those sorts of things.
So questions we might
be able to answer
in this setting would be, what
does this service actually
depend on?
You saw the Istio use cases
earlier today at the keynote.
There's some similarities
to what you'll see here.
If I'm trying to
find the shortest
path between two nodes in a
network, how would I find that?
And then the one that
we'll walk through here
is, what is the impact of
a service outage in my SaaS
application?
So imagine I'm modeling
an infrastructure.
I've got a SaaS application.
And this SaaS
application consists
of a couple of web interfaces
and maybe an external API
that my clients are consuming.
Each of these in turn is
reliant on internal APIs.
And those APIs are reliant
on other internal APIs.
At the end of the
day, eventually I've
got to get data from somewhere.
And a couple of these APIs
are querying a database,
and one of them is
querying a search index.
So when the system's
healthy, everybody's green.
But imagine I've got
some spike in the CPU
on one of my databases, right?
I see a time series getting
woven into my graph model,
and I see the CPU has spiked.
Clearly, if that
database spikes,
then this API is
going to be affected,
the other upstream
API will be affected,
and then my web
interfaces are going
to go out or be in trouble.
So while this might be a
very obvious easy to eyeball
scenario in a 12-node
network, imagine this
if you've got hundreds or
even thousands of services.
And how would I
predict what's going
to happen based on some outage?
I might use this
information in order
to deploy limited
extra resources.
Maybe I've got budget.
Where's my biggest
point of failure?
Where's my susceptibility?
Or where's my anchor client
going to get affected?
I might want to put
whatever extra budget
I have toward making sure
that that one is bulletproof.
Here's a mockup
generated by us that
walks through this use case.
You see an Elasticsearch,
a node that's laboring,
and it's affecting JanusGraph
and a Spring Boot API going
upstream.
You see some tabular data on the
right telling us a little bit
about what alarm has
gone off and why.
And down at the bottom
here on the next,
you see some sort
of a time frame
that I might be zooming
forward or back.
Maybe I could rewind
the clock a little bit
and figure out what was it that
happened last hour that caused
my Elasticsearch node to spike.
How might I do this
in supply chain?
So in supply chain, there
are several graphs that
can be modeled in this space.
You've got the
suppliers and how they
interoperate with each other.
You've got the actual bill of
materials of the finished good.
It consists of
some raw materials,
and some subcomponents, and
subcomponents of subcomponents.
You've got
transportation networks.
How does this actually
get from factory to shelf?
So questions that
we like to ask here
are things like, what would
happen if, God forbid,
there was a--
to shipments-- if there's
an earthquake here today?
Where are my bottlenecks
in my supplier network?
Again, trying to
address extra budget.
Maybe I can do something to help
bulletproof my supply chain.
And then for those
of us from Texas,
what finished products
are affected when
we have a flood in Houston?
So here's a contrived
supplier network.
Imagine I've got some
cars that I'm assembling.
And I've got engines
and cylinders.
I've got blocks, assemblers,
and finished products.
I've also got a
bill of material.
In this case, I've
got an engine that's
composed of a block and a
head inside of the block.
I've got pistons and cylinders.
If I put the two
together, then what I see
is the bill of material that may
flow through my supply chain.
So here's your
time series again.
It turns out each
of these suppliers,
they have inventory on hand.
So I've got some of my
engines on the shelf already.
And then I want to
simulate this disruption.
So imagine this supplier down
at the bottom is in Houston.
Obviously, he goes out.
The supply lane
actually gets affected,
as does that next supplier.
This supplier here is
affected, because as you see,
he's got no inventory on
hand in September, right?
He cannot weather the
storm metaphorically.
This other supplier, he actually
has some inventory on hand.
So he's got some capacity
to continue to meet his SLAs
even after the flood.
You also see the
bottom supplier.
He's feeding into this supplier.
So he's unaffected as well.
So here you see, again, where
the time series in the graph
tells you a better
view of the whole.
Here's another visual mockup
of supply chain disruption
simulator.
This is on our website,
where you can actually
geocode, and draw simulated
outages based on your supplier
network, and simulate
the effects of an outage
and how you might want to try to
reroute some of your supplies.
How might we do this in a
financial services setting?
In financial services,
you see graph identifying
fraudulent activity.
You can use the
social network model
for criminal network detection.
And then in this one, we'll
walk through evaluating
complex structured products.
So imagine, how would
I consider valuing
something that's not
overly obvious what
the current value is?
So in the first two
examples, we were
talking through use cases that
might be consumed by a finished
product.
But in this case, imagine you've
got a data scientist who's
testing some theses.
He's got lots of data, some
public, some not so public.
And he's trying
to figure out, how
do I value something based on
all of these different data
sets that I might not be
able to assimilate just yet?
So in this case, we're
going to value a REIT.
For those of you who
don't know what a REIT is,
it's essentially a Real
Estate Investment Trust.
And what that means
is it's a big basket
of real estate properties
that you value in totality.
So in our REIT, we've
got two properties.
One property is a
shopping mall in Oklahoma,
and the other one is a
water park in Florida.
And we've been able to
model that the shopping
mall in Oklahoma
actually is managed
by a professional
property manager
and also has two
tenants that are in it.
We've got some public data
about the value of this REIT.
And we see that
it is trending up.
And possibly what I've also
got is some not so public data,
where I've got a way to
capture foot traffic.
Maybe this node at the
bottom is my anchor tenant.
And I've now been able
to determine that there's
some correlation between foot
traffic and my anchor tenant
and the value of my
publicly-traded REIT.
Maybe if I've tested
enough theses,
I'm confident enough
in that hypothesis
that I might be willing to
trade ahead of that information.
So hopefully you see a
couple of different use cases
and scenarios where coupling the
graph with the time series data
is very powerful.
And now I'm going to
turn it over to Misha.
He's going to tell
you how this actually
can come to life on GCP.
MISHA BRUKMAN: Thank you, Brian.
So as we mentioned
earlier, JanusGraph
is an open source scalable
distributed graph database.
It's an Apache licensed project.
It's backed by the
Linux Foundation.
There are a number of users and
developers of this project now.
It's quite popular.
And it's growing very quickly.
JanusGraph provides a variety
of support for different storage
back ends as well as
indexing back ends.
And here we're going to
explore how to use JanusGraph
with a Bigtable
back end for storage
and Elasticsearch for indexing.
Brian alluded to this earlier.
So there's a project
called Apache TinkerPop.
And TinkerPop itself
is also an Apache
licensed open source project.
And it provides the framework
for open source graph
modeling and computation.
And it is hosted at the
Apache Software Foundation.
It also provides the
Gremlin query language
that is used for querying
these property graphs.
As Brian mentioned, JanusGraph
supports the property graph
model.
And all the examples that you
saw are property graph models.
Gremlin is quite a popular
querying language for graphs.
And it's supported by over
15 popular graph databases.
Here's an example of
deployment architecture
of how you can deploy a
scalable graph database on GCP.
So there's a
solution white paper
that we've published at the URL.
And what you'll see is
that in that solution,
JanusGraph is running
containerized on GKE
together with Elasticsearch.
And JanusGraph connects
to Elastic for indexing.
And it's using Cloud Bigtable
as the storage back end.
And in front of it,
there's a load balancer.
So you would run a number of
different JanusGraph instances,
which themselves are stateless,
and your applications would
talk to the load balancer and be
routed to one of the JanusGraph
instances.
So what is Cloud Bigtable?
"Bigtable is a sparse,
distributed, persistent,
multidimensional sorted map."
That's the description
from the paper
that we published in 2006.
Let's dive into some of the
details behind what this is.
So Bigtable is a distributed
key multi-value store.
So for a single key, you can
store many different values.
Bigtable is sparse in that
if you don't write data
in particular in
a number of cells,
it does not cost you
any storage space.
So you can store data in rows
that is relevant to them,
and you don't need to fill out
every single cell with null
or placeholder values.
Bigtable supports
atomic operations.
So you can modify any single
set of values in a single row,
in a single transaction,
and that will be atomic.
Bigtable provides a single
index, which is the row key,
and the row keys are
stored in sorted order.
So you have a sorted map.
Here you see an illustration
of what a subset of a table
would be in Bigtable.
And the various values here
are how you would address them.
So there are column families.
And inside them are
column qualifiers.
And the way to
address a single cell
is with the combination of
row, column family, and column
qualifier.
And that said, the map
actually also includes
a timestamp dimension.
So the full mapping
of values in Bigtable
is with a row key,
a column, which
is a combination
of column family
and an optional qualifier,
and a 64-bit timestamp.
And the values in Bigtable
are uninterpreted byte arrays.
So you can store anything
from JSON to protocol buffers
to snippets of
audio or thumbnails
or anything that is relevant
to your particular use case.
Every cell in Bigtable,
as I mentioned,
has an int64 attached to it.
So the way to think about is
is that Bigtable's actually
a three-dimensional database.
Every cell can store a
number of different versions,
and they do not have to match
across the different cells
in the same row
or different rows.
So you can store
different versions
of the data, which
means you can store
time series within each cell.
So Bigtable comes by default
with first-class support
for time series.
And you can also have an
optional garbage collection
enabled for this.
So you can keep writing
data, and older data
will automatically expire and
be garbage collected and removed
for you.
Let's talk a bit about
how the requests are
routed in Bigtable.
So clients connect to
a single end point,
which is a combination of
load balancing and proxy
layer to Bigtable,
before they're routed
to Bigtable server nodes.
In the following
couple slides, I
will remove the load
balancing and proxy layer.
But keep in mind that
it is still there,
and clients do not
actually directly connect
to Bigtable nodes, which
means they don't need
to do any discovery,
they don't need
to update anything based on the
membership of a given cluster.
Clients connect to
Bigtable server nodes.
But Bigtable itself
is actually stateless.
The data in Bigtable is actually
stored in our distributed file
system, which is Colossus, which
is the successor to the Google
File System.
And here you can see the
sections of data, A, B, C,
D, and E, which each of those
is a subset of a single Bigtable
table.
So each one of those
stores a sorted subset
of the keys in that table.
Also note that each
Bigtable node owns
a number of these data regions,
and it has exclusive access
to them.
So this is what allows Bigtable
to provide atomic updates
within a single row.
So an entire single row is
contained in exactly one
of those locations.
And exactly one
Bigtable server node
is responsible for
managing that data,
both from a read and
write perspective.
So now imagine we have one of
the server nodes is getting
quite a lot of activity
from the clients,
because it is managing a number
of the popular data sets.
So it's Managing A, B, and C,
and so it gets more traffic
from the clients
than other nodes.
What we can easily
do is just reassign
the ownership of the data
from one node to another.
Note that there's no
data motion taking place
because none of the nodes
themselves are actually
storing the data locally.
They provide
support for caching,
but there's no durable storage
at the Bigtable node server
level.
The data stays in Colossus.
There's no movement
regardless of how many
gigabytes or terabytes
you're storing.
And this reassignment
is very quick.
And the clients
don't even notice.
And again, they
don't need to know
that they need to connect
to a different server node,
because their requests
are transparently routed
to a different server
in response to Bigtable
behind the scenes
doing the optimization
to rebalance the data such that
we provide good performance
regardless of the scale.
Now, given that we're able
to easily reassign the data
ownership from one
node to another,
this means that it's
quite easy for us
to scale the cluster up and
down by adding or removing nodes
to the cluster and
from the cluster.
Because, again, there's
no data stored durably
on a Bigtable node, this
means they are stateless.
And if they're stateless,
we can easily move them.
So the only thing
that they store
is a cache of knowing what
it is that they're currently
responsible for, which
we can easily reassign.
So this means also that a
Bigtable node disappearing
means that there
is no data loss.
So Bigtable has no single
point of failure here.
If you lose a node,
there is no data loss,
because the data is replicated
and stored durably in Colossus.
Because the nodes don't talk to
each other in Cloud Bigtable,
Bigtable provides linear
scalability and performance.
As you add nodes to
a Bigtable cluster
to make the cluster larger,
you get linear scalability
and throughput in
performance, because the nodes
don't do any coordination,
because the transactions only
happen locally at a single
Bigtable server node, which
means also we can scale up
and down without any downtime,
again, because of the
dynamic reassignment
of the data from one node to
another behind the scenes.
Today we're really
proud to announce
that we're launching replication
to general availability.
So this means that within
a Bigtable instance,
you can create more than
one Bigtable cluster.
And when you write data
once to a single location,
it will be replicated
asynchronously
to a different cluster.
A single cluster provides
strong consistency in reads
and writes.
Once you switch to a
multi-cluster model,
it will be eventually
consistent across clusters.
There are no manual
steps that you
need to take to ensure
data is replicated.
It will be done for you
automatically and synchronized.
There are no repair steps.
There are no management.
There's literally
nothing you need
to do other than to say,
please add another cluster
to this instance.
And the use cases that this
is quite applicable for
are both
high-availability serving
for low-latency use
cases, as well as
for separating analytics
from server use cases,
such that you don't impact
your serving traffic
from large-scale analytics.
And this is going to be GA
as of tomorrow, July 25.
It will increase the SLA
from 99.5% to 99.95%.
And there's zero-touch failover
for high-availability use
cases.
As I mentioned, the
Bigtable data model
supports keys in sorted order.
And then there's a bunch
of cells that in each row,
you can store data.
And so you have cells,
and there's columns,
and the data there
is sorted by column.
And so JanusGraph, the way
it stores a graph in Bigtable
is by storing the vertices
as the row keys in Bigtable.
And as Brian
mentioned, there are
properties on both the
vertices as well as the edges.
And so the properties on
the vertices as well as
the edges and the
properties of the edges
are all stored within the
row for a single vertex.
This makes it
really easy and fast
to find an arbitrary
vertex and then find
the edges that are
outgoing from that vertex,
because they're in the
row, and they're always
stored in that row
together with the vertex.
Brian also mentioned the
applicability of time series
data to a number of
these use cases from IoT
to finance to supply chain.
OpenTSDB is a very popular
open source time series
database that stores millisecond
level precision time series
data.
And it scales
horizontally to support
millions of writes per second.
OpenTSDB chose a particular
schema to support on Bigtable.
And here you can see the row
key itself is quite complex.
It includes the metric, a
timestamp, and key value pairs
for the tags.
Note that in front of the
row key, they added a salt.
This is to help
distribute the load, such
that if you have
metrics that maybe have
similar keys, that
you don't hotspot,
since we're keeping
everything in sorted order.
And then the data is stored
in the different cells
of the columns of that row.
So now you can see that with
the integrations that Bigtable
provides for both time
series with OpenTSDB
and graphs with JanusGraph,
we can support the use
cases that Brian
spoke about earlier
in the different industries.
So Bigtable provides both
of these types of use cases
a fully managed
petabyte-scale database
that scales linearly
for increased throughput
while also providing
low latency because
of the sorted nature of keys and
the ease of finding the keys.
And it's great for the time
series and graph use cases
that we have discussed.
So let's talk
about, what would it
look like to deploy a combined
architecture of both time
series and graph on
GCP with Bigtable?
So here you have a
sample application
that is using both JanusGraph
as well as OpenTSDB.
OpenTSDB, JanusGraph,
and Elastic
are all running
containerized on Kubernetes.
They're both using Bigtable.
Obviously, each one of them
will have a separate data
set encoded in different ways.
So they can use
different tables,
but they can use the same
Bigtable table instance.
We have an application that
is providing an API that
is talking to JanusGraph.
And we have data coming
in through Pub/Sub
that is being consumed by data
flow that is both publishing
the time series data to OpenTSDB
as well as sending requests
to the API server.
Here's an example of how
you would deploy OpenTSDB.
We have a similar solution,
as we talked about earlier,
for JanusGraph.
There's also a simple
way of deploying
OpenTSDB be together with
Bigtable using Kubernetes
on Google Cloud.
And we've open sourced a
Helm chart for JanusGraph.
That makes it really
easy to deploy
JanusGraph on Kubernetes.
This is open source from GitHub.
And we will have pointers at
the end where you can find it.
And our partners at Expero wrote
this Container Graph Sample
Service.
That is the application
that I spoke about earlier.
It's a drop wizard-based
demo application.
It is also open
source on GitHub.
And what it does
is it's ingesting
metrics data, the data that
is coming in, to Pub/Sub.
And the application that I
spoke about earlier, that
is the application
that they wrote.
That is the container
graph service
that is contacted by
data flow and that
is talking to JanusGraph.
And what this
application implements
itself is a graph API, where you
can add and remove containers.
You can find upstream
and downstream services.
You can gather the dependencies.
So you can do that graph walk
that Brian mentioned earlier.
If something happens
to a particular node,
how can I find the upstream
and downstream dependencies?
What will be affected?
And you can add and
remove containers.
So this architecture is both
a deployment architecture
of what you might deploy
on Google Cloud as well
as the graph that it will
encode upon deployment.
So it models itself
as a graph, very meta.
So how would you
connect to JanusGraph?
As we mentioned, JanusGraph
works with TinkerPop.
And TinkerPop project
provides a number
of drivers in the
different languages.
And there are project-supported
client libraries in .NET,
JavaScript, Java, and Python,
as well as third party-supported
Scala, Clojure,
and Go libraries.
When you write queries in
TinkerPop in the TinkerPop
library, the queries
themselves are not text.
They're very fluent, and
they're written to the language
that you're using.
So in this case,
in Java, this is
what a query would look like.
So you get all the
benefits of your IDE,
all of the type
checking system, rather
than combining together
concatenating strings
and then sending them to
be processed by the server.
In this case, the query
that we're showing here
is not very graphy.
It's not very complicated.
This is just for
illustration purposes.
Many of the queries that
you'll see in practice
will be more
complicated and there'll
be quite a bit more to them.
In this case, the query
that you'll see here,
this just retrieves a list
of running containers.
But there's much more
you can do with this.
A query in graphs.
So this is Gremlin.
This is the graph
query language.
It's actually
called a traversal.
Internally, it runs
a state machine.
And there are a bunch
of steps to a traversal.
And they will fall into one
of these five categories.
So when you see at
the bottom here,
you have G, which is a graph.
You will select vertices.
This is a map phase.
You will filter define
a specific vertex.
You will find out all the
outgoing edges by label.
And then you'll select
a particular attribute
on the outgoing.
And just so this will find you
all the names of all the people
that are known by that
person in that first segment.
So as you've seen, you can
use both graph and time series
databases to solve a number
of different problems
in a number of different
industry verticals.
This will give you both
the micro view as well as
the macro view of
the situation, allow
you to explore the data at a
high level through a graph,
and then dive deep
to understand what
is the low-level behavior of the
system at the micro level using
the time series.
And JanusGraph and
OpenTSDB provide
scalable implementations of both
the graph and time series data
models.
And they can be both scaled
as stateless services
on top of a scalable
database, such as Bigtable.
As next steps, as
Brian and I mentioned,
there are a number
of resources that you
can take a look at to learn
more about both everything
that we've talked about
as well as find all
the demos that we've mentioned.
So first, there's the Cloud
Bigtable home page, where you
can learn more about Bigtable.
Regarding JanusGraph,
the first link
there is a solution of how to
run JanusGraph with Bigtable.
That is the architecture
that I showed earlier.
There's the Expero
demo container graph
project that you'll find next.
And JanusGraph.org has a number
of pointers to both our users
and use cases.
Who's running it?
How they're running it.
What does it support?
What language versions that
you might want to use with it.
Regarding Gremlin, the
graph query language,
there's an excellent
introduction
to the Gremlin language
by Kelvin Lawrence.
That is the first link there.
It's an entire book.
It's open source.
It's also on GitHub.
But you can read it at this URL.
It provides an in-depth
tutorial that you probably
want to take a look at.
If you're going to
use a property graph,
you want to learn Gremlin.
And there's also
a learning program
from our partners at
Expero that will also
help you understand or learn
Gremlin and become a Gremlin
expert.
There are obviously also
forums and mailing lists,
where, if you have
complicated questions,
you can ask questions
about Gremlin.
And there's Stack Overflow--
very active users
on Stack Overflow
who are also developers
of the Gremlin language.
Regarding OpenTSDB,
as I mentioned,
we have a solution here
of how to deploy OpenTSDB
on Google Cloud with Bigtable.
And there's also a number of
visualizations in the gallery
that Expero put
together that you
might want to take a look at.
[MUSIC PLAYING]